let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right let's begin with this because
we're going to see and hear a lot of
this
in the coming weeks here is allison
camerota on
cnn talking about what what she thinks
will happen
if roe v wade is overturned listen i
think one of the interesting discussions
about abortion is that the country is
generally
divided i mean almost split right in
half about how they
view it however in the latest gallup
polls
20 of the country oh i should say only
20
of the country wants to outlaw it okay
so you can feel differently
about the different nuances of it but
only 20 wants to outlaw it
and that's ultimately you know obviously
what would happen if roe
versus wade were done away with and so
it's just interesting i mean
obviously we're segueing into a
political stance here
but if the country does you know
would support the direction that this is
going in
well this is why uh when uh
republican presidents nominate justices
to the court
they try to pretend that it's some
mystery what their views are
about roe versus wade because they know
the country is against them on this
issue
yeah so alisa camarata is either stupid
or lying
uh or she could be both i don't mean to
limit her okay i don't want to limit the
possibilities here
but no overturning roe would not mean
that abortion is outlawed
okay in fact if roe is overturned the
next day
abortion is still going to be legal
everywhere
the laws are not directly affected at
all by overturning roe v wade
no what it would do is it would make it
possible
for individual states to pass laws that
would then restrict or possibly ban the
practice
it enables them to do it it doesn't mean
that it happens
um and some will do that some some
states will pass laws like that some
won't
does camarada think that california and
new york are going to ban abortion
because roe is gone
no if anything they're going to pass
laws that
just encourage it even more in
retribution
um only the very strongly and
overwhelmingly conservative states
will ban the practice i think what's
going to happen what's what's going to
you know you're gonna have some you have
a few states that ban it out right a few
states that like i said go even further
in the other direction
i think what's gonna happen in the
majority of states is that you're gonna
find more
restrictions and that's in line with
what most americans feel and what their
what their opinion is of the practice
now of course when it comes to something
like this it doesn't matter how most
americans feel about it
this this is this a basic human right
that's being infringed upon you've got
60 million dead babies since roe v wade
um i don't care if every single american
in the country
loves it uh it it it's still it still
should be banned and if we could ban it
across the country i would be in favor
of doing that
but that's just not the reality that's
not what we're talking about here
um you you would need something like a
constitutional amendment
uh protecting the personhood rights of
of unborn children which i would favor
but we're not anywhere close to that
happening roe v wade simply allows
states to make choices
and that's if if americans can be made
to understand this
then i think the majority
would be in favor of overturning roe v
wade
but keep this in mind i don't know what
the polls say but you're going to see a
lot of polls
how do polls how do americans feel about
overturning roe v wade
whenever you read those polls keep in
mind that a large number of the people
taking the poll
don't actually know what overturning roe
v wade means
and a lot of them are going to think
that it means
exactly what allison camerata says
because that's what the media is telling
them
okay number two uh take a look at this
this happened at a car dealership in the
bronx
so that's a gang fight that broke out at
the car dealership
but uh in if you're if you're listening
to this on the audio podcast it's
at a car dealership bullets start flying
and at the bottom of the screen there's
a a dad sitting
on a couch i guess in the waiting room
with with looks like three or four kids
um and as soon as the the bulls start
flying he
he he lays on top of the kids
shielding them from the bullets actually
he took a bullet in the thigh i believe
he's gonna be okay his kids are okay
if he hadn't been lying on top of them
who knows where that bullet will would
have gone
but you see i think with this footage
you see sort of the the heights and
depths
of masculinity um the contrast really
it's
real masculinity versus fake masculinity
and you
and you see both of those things uh
[Music]
illustrated in that video and you know
certainly in our culture we could use we
could use a lot more of of the kind of
masculinity that you saw which is the
real
which is real authentic masculinity the
kind that you saw happening there
playing out at the bottom of the screen
that's what we could use a lot more of
in this country number three the media
today is very disturbed very disturbed
very troubled very very troubled uh so
deeply troubled because
trump made a joke at his rally last
night about a reporter being thrown to
the side by cops let's listen to that
they grabbed him they were grabbing them
left and right
sometimes they grab they grab one guy
i'm a reporter i'm a reporter
get out of here they threw him aside
like he was a little bag of popcorn
but no but i mean honestly when you
watch the crap that we've all had to
take so long
when you see that it's actually you
don't want to do that but when you see
it it's actually a beautiful sight
it's a beautiful sight
and they had the same thing on some
other streets and the whole thing was
gone and i haven't heard of any real
problem in minneapolis since that
happened i mean they were just burning
down the city and that
idiot was standing there this is a
friendly protest and it's right
and behind him was like 10 blocks of
fire was
now i have to agree that is that is
extremely troubling i think
um i am also disturbed by that
i mean trump says they threw him aside
like a bag of popcorn
that is no way to treat a bag of popcorn
the fact that trump thinks the fact that
trump thinks of popcorn as a thing that
you throw to the side
what kind of analogy is that throw to
the side like a bag of pop who throws
their bag of popcorn to the side
so if i give you a bag of popcorn you're
just going to toss it to the side that's
not
i mean is that what he does at a movie
theater they hand him his large popcorn
just she just chucks it over like that
i think this statement from trump
reveals a really problematic attitude
about popcorn
and that is a national conversation that
i think we need to have
number four new york post has this story
i think this has already been announced
but uh here it is again it says actor
jim caviezel
who played jesus in 2004 as the passion
of the christ said
writer director mel gibson has written a
forthcoming sequel
mel gibson just sent me the third
picture of the third draft it's coming
he told breitbart it's called the
passion of the christ
resurrection it's going to be the
biggest film in world history while
kaveesa 51 may talk a big game the first
film was no slouch made on the
made on the relatively modest budget of
30 million
it took took in 622 million worldwide
um let's see it and then it says so
what the new film the actor said would
depict his uh
jesus's biblical resurrection and the
events that followed now
um yes first of all biggest film in the
world
that's i think that that may
that could very well be the case this
movie is going to make a gazillion
dollars
passion of the christ made 622 million
um and keep in mind that's not even
adjusted for inflation but also keep in
mind that was a
a movie that was rated r uh you know not
not not really a kid friendly not a
movie you're gonna bring like your
eight-year-old to right
um because it's it's pretty gruesome now
it is actually what happened to christ
so
i think it's a great film uh but not for
very young kids
if we're talk if we're doing passion of
christ resurrection then probably it's
going to be a little bit more
family-friendly it's not going to be
quite as gruesome i would think
this is a mel gibson film so you never
know um and so if there's
if it's not rated r so you're taking a a
bible movie not rated r made by a
a mainstream and great film director and
mel gibson i think that's a
that's a billion dollar movie at least
for sure um
my only question though is how much so
what i've read in the past
is that this movie is going to be it's
going to tell the story of jesus
his resurrection up to the ascension and
that's going to be the whole movie
now if we were going into the book of
acts and we we were
and mel gibson is showing us what's
going on with peter and paul
that would be obviously a great film and
i would love to watch that movie
i'm just wondering if there's enough
biblical material between resurrection
and ascension to make a movie
because the gospels cover that in like
four sentences
so this if that's if that's the time
frame we're covering
then mel gibson's going to have to
freelance quite a bit
and add in a lot um so that could get a
little dicey
but uh i think it's i think it's great
and this is
you know it just it kind of shows you
how much
hollywood hates christians that they're
not making
bible movies like five bible movies a
year
because these movies make a ton of money
there's a huge audience for them
even when they're not good mel gibson
makes a great one
some of the bible movies we get aren't
even good they still make a ton of money
there's a huge hungry audience for this
material and yet for the most part
unless mel gibson comes along mainstream
hollywood is not making these movies
uh with a few exceptions okay five
finally rioting in portland continued
last night
as always um but then the antifa riders
took a break
from the rioting for a little musical
interlude
actually they started moshing at least
that's what this is supposedly
is a video of but you tell me let's
let's let's take a look
[Applause]
i do not know this cultural tradition
okay that is not a mosh pit first of all
that's that's more like a tickle fight a
tickle pit
if you will tickle pits by the way would
be a great name for maybe an indie band
but that video really just underscores
the important point that i always like
to highlight which is that antifa
are domestic terrorists yes but they're
also enormous
dorks and let's never lose sight of that
never forget that
these are the saddest flabbiest
scrawniest most awkward
weakest most pathetic little punks
you'll ever encounter
in your life but then when a bunch of
them have crowbars
and and bricks and stuff yes they're
dangerous
of course you could give a you could
give a whole bunch of 12 year old
cheerleaders crowbars and bricks and
they would be dangerous too
so you could give that to toddlers and
they'd be dangerous also that
that's not really telling you anything
about about the toughness of the
individual people
individually they're they're exactly
what you saw right there
but a whole big group of them yeah um
they are terrorists and and they are
dangerous
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content